>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FINAL EXAM WHERE THE
NEWS EXPERTS COMPETE TO SEE WHO
PAID THE CLOSEST ATTENTION TO
THE NEWS THIS WEEK.
TONIGHT A SPECIAL "THE FIVE"
FINAL EXAM.
JESSE WATTERS AND GREG GUTFELD
JOIN US FROM THE LARGEST CITY IN
THE UNITED STATES TONIGHT.
THE WINNER WILL FACE OFF NEXT
WEEK WITH THE 12-TIME JEOPARDY
CHAMPION.
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THE
UNSUBSTANTIATED ALLEGATION ON
MR. GREG GUTFELD'S T-SHIRT.
THEY WON'T DEDUCT POINTS FOR THE
INSULT YOU HAVE THROWN AT
MR. WATERS.
WATTERS.
>> FAKE NEWS.
I DON'T GET INVOLVED.
>> I THOUGHT I WAS HAVING A
REMATCH WITH DANA.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW THE RULES.
I WILL REPEAT THEM FOR VIEWERS.
HANDS ON BUZZERS.
THE FIRST ONE THAT BUZZES IN
GETS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
ASKING THE QUESTION.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG YOU LOSE A
POINT.
BEST OF 5 WINS.
SIMPLE.
YOU READY?
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: QUESTION ONE:
WHICH TELEVISION BILLONAIRE WAS
NAMED A BIBLICICAL FIGURE LOST
$50-MILLION ON A WEIGHT
WATCHER'S INVESTMENT AFTER FEWER
PEOPLE SIGNED UP FOR ITS DIET?
>> OPRAH WINFREY.
>> OH!
>> YOU KNOW HE HIT BEFORE THE
QUESTION ENDED.
>> Tucker: I AM NOT.
THERE OUR JUDGES WILL HAVE TO
ASSESS.
THE BUZZ COUNT.
WAS IT OPRAH WINFREY?
>> $50-MILLION OPRAH WINFREY
LOST WHO OWNED PART OF THE
COMPANY.
I HOPE YOU DIDN'T PAY AN ANALYST
FOR THAT EVALUATION.
>> Tucker: DID YOU KNOW OPRAH
WAS A BIBLICAL NAME?
>> NO.
>> IT'S HARPO BACKWARDS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Tucker: HANDS ON BUZZER.
QUESTION 2.
THIS IS MULTIPLE CHOICE.
THE PRESIDENT'S WORKING LUNCH
WITH THE DICTATOR OF NORTH KOREA
THE DESSERT WAS A CERTAIN
VEGETABLE.
GREEN BEANS, MUSHROOMS OR
CHINESE WATER CHESTNUTS?
>> THE SECOND ONE.
THE MUSHROOMS.
>> Tucker: WAS IT WOOD EAR
MUSROOMS?
>> LISTEN TO THIS FOR THE
MINNISH.
A TRADITIONAL VIETNAM DESSERT OF
MUSHROOMS IN A LIGHT, SUGARY
SYRUP.
>> Tucker: HOW DID YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> I AM A CHEF.
I COOK EVERY NIGHT FOR THE
CHILDREN.
I GO DOWN TO THE ORPHANAGE AND
COOK.
>> EVERYTHING HE IS SAYING IS
WRONG.
>> I AM A SELFLESS HUMAN BEING.
>> Tucker: QUESTION 3.
2020 CANDIDATE AMY IS IN THE
NEWS FOR STRANGE BEHAVIOR
DEALING WITH HER STAFF.
A FORMER AIDE WITNESSED THE
SENATOR EATING HER SALAD WITH
WHICH UNUSUAL ITEM.
SCISSORS, A COMB OR HER BARE
HANDS?
>> A COMB.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" AMY
BERATED A STAFF MEMBER FOR
FAILING TO BRING HER A FORK WITH
HER SALAD.
SHEATE THE SALAD USING THE COMB
FROM HER BAG AND THEN GAVE IT TO
HER AIDE TO CLEAN IT.
>> TUCKER, DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
COLLUSION STORY AND AMY HAVE IN
COMMON?
A DIRTY COMEY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
QUESTION 4, WHICH LOUD MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WHO USED TO BE A
BARTENDER IS NOW A SWORD
WEILDING SUPER HERO IN A COMIC
BOOK?
>> AOC.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU BE MORE
SPECIFIC?
>> ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
>> Tucker: WAS IT
AOC?
>> IT'S A BIRD OR PLANE OR AOC.
THE NEW YORK CONGRESSWOMAN IS
NOW THE STAR OF A COMIC BOOK.
ONE COVER SHOWS HER WITH A SWORD
AND SUPER WOMAN STYLE OUTFIT
WITH THE CAPTION "NEW PARTY, WHO
THIS?"
>> Tucker: 2 NOTES FROM THE
JUDGES.
KEEP HANDS ON BUZZERS AND THIS
QUESTION IS WORTH 2 POINTS.
>> WHAT!
>> Tucker: I DON'T MAKE THE
DECISIONS HERE.
>> YOU JUST CHANGED THE RULES.
>> Tucker: I DO WHAT I AM TOLD.
NEVER APOLOGIZE AND NEVER
EXPLAIN.
FINAL QUESTION.
IF YOU WISH YOUR BEER TASTED
MORE LIKE MARSH MALLOWS YOU ARE
IN LOOK.
WHICH BEER TASTES LIKE A NEW
BREAKFAST CEREAL?
>> LUCKY CHARMS.
>> LUCKY CHARMS FAVORED BEER.
MADE OF TOASTED MARSHMALLOWS AND
A LEPRECHAUN TOO.
>> Tucker: ARE IMPRESSIVE.
I WILL GIVE YOU MY MUG NEXT TIME
I SEE YOU.
WILL FACE OFF AGAINST THE
JEOPARDY CHAMPION.
>> YOU KEEP PROMISING ME THE
MUG.
>> I KNEW ALL OF THE ANSWERS.
HE IS CLOSER TO THE BUZZER.